[Music]
in heavy sleeper news that's me dude not
me at all I have to have earplugs in
really dude white noise will save your
sleep it is awesome I love it
Jones out a lot of life I got it because
it was like but like now I like I love
sleeping with it I'll try it it just
sounds like a AC is on or a fan is on
yeah I hear my AC 2 and A Bug's it just
goes it needs to be a constant 2 John
not the AC I'll turn off the AC
interesting submitted by gambling is bad
[ __ ] you [ __ ] that hurts my
feelings I love gambling
me too what you offended why would you
say something like that you're so rude
that's like saying doughnuts are bad yes
we know it's bad but never I'll never
admit it but they're not bad for your
soul they make you unhappy mm-hmm and
we're life apart you're right yep and
when you win from gambling what happens
smiles I don't know anybody that goes I
love taking next month's rent and then
gambling it because now you could pay
for two months if you want or you could
be homeless if you lose we like living
on the edge but I'm not attached to
materialistic things
soccer star says a rat ate his foot
while he was sleeping
what Apple can wake up oh he must have
been on heavy drugs yeah yet to be on
the comp a soccer star a former English
soccer star named Gary mother mother
don't touch my butt my butt my butt you
have you gotta be on it you gotta be
this is Gary woman don't touch my butt
oh he's all he was like he touched your
butt like he looks like you those aren't
touching but no what if he's a nice guy
and look how big that falls legs were
holy [ __ ] damn bog way to go
I don't know I didn't know rats were
known to bite young things and eat in a
foot like I've heard a lot scary story
of them eating your stomach if you like
put them in a cage yeah well you'd never
torture style oh my god I just saw a
video yesterday of this Chinese guy he
could he hacked a Chinese woman to death
on the street and then started ripping
her intestines out of her stomach it was
dope goes wrong with you Gina yeah you
worry me it was a married couple they
got into a fight it's Mary yeah yeah
yeah I thought it was a random act of
violence I was like why who's like
ripping the intestines if it's out of
marriages yeah it makes sense I don't
think I'm gonna invite you back on
taking news you disturb me every time
you know people ask me why a watch it's
because it makes me appreciate life more
you know I mean because like you're so
positive yeah because it's like [ __ ] it
once and so because there's so many
videos people just randomly dying for no
reason you need you need you need what
is it that it's like a reality check
that's what you yeah it's like it's a
humbling reality check what if she's
just a low-key [ __ ] serial killer
that's like [ __ ] catharsis hard I
don't think we don't know I know yeah
and that's what's like keeping her
[ __ ] balance it's not like it's like
I would kill like my rich husband so I
can take there you know that way oh my
photo in Vegas the fur coat I was
wearing I left that way oh my
and the caption says this is what I'm
gonna wear when I find out my old rich
husband died from mysterious causes yes
/ can you wear that again next time
you're on JK news just that no the dress
no the whole thing my sweats on
underneath yeah yeah but you tell I was
like yeah that's my friend we should all
dress nice to BJ kake news
Oh dog a prompt way would you say a
formal you can wear that
oh where am i over my Buffy Athene
perfect dress you look like a badass
[ __ ] okay what makes you a badass [ __ ]
if your tits are kind of all over the
place no no no you gotta look like you
gotta look like you date the mob latex
type [ __ ]
you said yeah yeah latex that no I could
kind of see that like a latex one-piece
like yeah yeah because they can't afford
super leather right yes like a pleather
yeah yeah yeah maybe not best true latex
is a little S&M what are you gonna wear
is that where the shirt with the tuxedo
parts gonna have a big collar with the
shirt unbuttoned like that it in the
[ __ ] gold chip yeah these two really
be dressed like the Dumb and Dumber
tuxedos yeah there we go he would not
wear that with the lapel here where the
[ __ ] cuffs only with just oh the
stripper mafia we have a barber he's
making up his own [ __ ] anyway this dude
Gary the boutique
yes something that last a man I can't
take you seriously it's ma b pu t t my
booty my boobies gonna be dope mister my
booty booby your table is ready
yeah dope so he was in a trip in South
Africa and he had to cut that trip short
because you woke up in the middle of the
night he's 57 by the way he has type 1
diabetes but oh he got dead foot yes he
has very little feeling in us all
rats eat live you know like what's one
here's maybe it was the meat and it was
hungry yeah because his daughter ran
into his room because she said that she
was bitten by something
he's also English in English Englishmen
feet smell like [ __ ]
oh maybe cheese rats like G oh my god oh
you're right and then the same back to
you that's in our [ __ ] toenail [ __ ]
that's the same as cheese cheese on your
wrist yeah she's on her wrist cheese
that's what people who sell watches when
you take on your watch for cleaning
there's risk cheese there is no cheese
no I think it has to be like leather or
something there's no way your risk
genius I want to have risk cheese a very
small where's mine do I have it wow I'm
surprised way [ __ ] is it this on
the dial M combat leaders is that risk
cheese yeah like yes that's risky
some people never take off their watches
oh there's so much it's just sweat and
dirt and all that not gonna clean it and
clean if someone brings in their wash to
clean you take it off [ __ ] Duncan
sometimes I have to take each a link of
the bracelet apart because there is so
much risk cheese then I can't just wipe
it that oh that's the same [ __ ] that's
on a poker chip
oh that greasy as wax yah I've never
been it's gross
why don't watch those poker chips at the
shittier casinos they're full of [ __ ]
grease and wax like whatever it is I
don't know what that thing is here you
read a tooth butter I learned it here in
Jacob teeth butter some people they
don't brush your teeth in it's just like
have you ever scraped just one your
tooth put the finger now and you scrape
it and there's like [ __ ] to the
butter I did a meet-and-greet once and
this guy came up to music oh my god so
nice to meet you smiled it was just all
tooth one like months worth of tooth
butter
without fail there's always someone in
the meeting greed that got mad tooth
butter it's not you it's not you you you
brush your teeth
what have you not known if you're just
brush it to you every time I mean I mean
you know you're lazy get an electric - I
gotta leave the house just brush the
teeth I seen some teeth decay on a young
person before and I was like what
or I seen one that was like orange rust
color Oh hint oh maybe they drank
something like color and it got caught
on the teeth butter man cuz I saw a
[ __ ] layer I saw a layer on top of
the tooth I would look it's hard like
it's hard not to stare like when they
smile and then I'm just like oh damn
layers of that [ __ ] I've never seen
tooth butter like that before it looks
crazy and there was like black spots
like he just ate a bag of peppers or
something black peppers so for those
people who just wanted like only inhale
yeah maybe feel so it yeah you smell it
sometimes I had a really bad hygiene in
junior high so I could kind of relate
because I would go weeks without
brushing my teeth I would go weeks
without showering oh yeah yeah I'd have
for showering I mean oh whoa and boy
smell
grunge boat we got grunt [ __ ] was I was
like all Kurt Cobain Nirvana like I just
[ __ ] never showered nasty boy alright
but anyway this dude with his foot right
what this [ __ ] pilgrim shoes you woke
up and he saw that his foot was just
covered in blood
oh no the rat bit into his foot so much
that he went down to the No
oh my god that rat is [ __ ] her wild me
it's got a taste for human now yeah so
zombies start dude rat [ __ ] bite
through everything I used to have so
yeah yeah what he said
what yeah how else would you pronounce
that
ma be bu TT that's how you say it
I like my but more space madness
I got mad at mad Malthus anyway so he
said unfortunately the rat had a nice
had had a nice meal and I hadn't been
able to feel it so his foots gone I've
gone he got he has a hole in missing a
chunk that's kind of question he was
like super athletic and all that and
then you got like that B is not a [ __ ]
what you got well there's a rat you do
you think it's like that just happened
because that transition always blows my
mind like people that are super athletic
and [ __ ] in like all of a sudden not
really when you think about it right
like maybe he did it so much for his
life that he's just so [ __ ] over it
and he doesn't want to do it he's like
I'm [ __ ] the worst thing of a worst
case of that it's not even like
naturally but like Christopher Reeves
goes from like Superman to pretty much a
quadriplegic like that's scary dude yeah
that was a freak accident
but when itself like really happened he
fell off a horse
Oh was it on it was an onset right I
don't think so from Superman dude I mean
wait you know he didn't really have
superpowers if you just acting like he's
still human
oh my god I'm so sorry Tina
[Music]